So for this quiz, I want you to think about why
we're so focused on how time scales with the size of
the input, rather than the absolute time it takes for a
particular execution to run. Check all the answers that are correct.
So the first choice is, we want to predict how long
it will take for a program to execute before we actually
run the program. The second choice is, we want to know
how the time will change as computers get faster. And through
the entire history of computing it's been the case that
the computer that you can buy for the same amount
of money a year from now is faster than the
computer that you can get for that price today. So
the third choice, we want to understand fundamental properties of
our algorithms, not things that are specific to a particular
input or machine. And the fourth choice is, we want
abstract answers to make sure they can never be wrong.